Bill Skarsgård has been working as an actor
since 2000, with some of his earliest roles
including a small role in a film called "White
Water Fury" in 2000 and a two-episode arc
on a miniseries called "Laura Trenter — Dad,
the Policeman" in 2002, both of which are
Swedish projects. A decade later, he began
his run as a main cast member on the horror
series "Hemlock Grove," which went on to have
three total seasons. However, it was his role
as Pennywise the Clown in the 2017 film adaptation
of Stephen King's "It" that really brought
public attention to the Swedish actor.
Since then, Skarsgård has starred in Season
1 of the horror anthology series "Castle Rock"
in 2018, reprised his role as Pennywise for
"It Chapter Two" in 2019, and acted in a string
of films, including "Nine Days" and "The Devil
All the Time," both of which came out in 2020.
He also voiced the character of Kro for Marvel's
"Eternals," which came out in late 2021. The
actor also has quite a few upcoming projects,
including "John Wick: Chapter 4" and a TV
drama called "Clark," in which the youngest
Skarsgård brother plays the titular character,
a charming yet infamous Swedish gangster.
Clearly, Skarsgård has a lot on his plate,
but, were he to find the time to play the
part, there is one iconic character that one
pop culture fan has in mind for him, and it's
the Joker.
Artist William Gray, who describes himself
on Instagram as a, quote, "creator of pop
culture-inspired Photoshop pieces," has made
Bill Skarsgård a frequent figure in his reimaginings
of popular character actors depicted as Gotham's
notorious Clown Prince of Crime. In recent
months, Skarsgård has appeared nearly a dozen
times on the artist's grid, shown in various
costumes and make-up looks in each stunning
rendering. The end results are proof that
the actor could make a terrifying version
of the villainous character. One of the more
recent pictures depicts a Skarsgård's Joker
being carted, Hannibal Lecter-style, into
Arkham Asylum. An image from October 2020,
and another from September 2020, show close-up
versions of the Joker.
One look at the comments of the photos, and
it is crystal clear that movie fans are on
board for Skarsgård as the Joker. With the
first photo, one user wrote,
"Holy s— that actually looks perfect ... in
my opinion."
Another user chimed in, complete with the
fire emoji,
"Will, you are a genius Bill Skarsgård would
be a perfect Joker."
With the third photo, yet another Instagram
user commented,
"I so want Skarsgård to be the next Joker."
Elsewhere in the comment thread, one user
simply wrote, "Creepy" with three clown emojis
tacked on.
Overall, it's safe to say that Gray has convinced
us that Skarsgård would fit right into the
role. Sure, he's not the only actor the artist
has reimagined as Joker (Johnny Depp, Crispin
Glover, and Jim Carrey also get the transformation
treatment), but Gray's vision of Skargård
as the bone-chilling criminal is arguably
one of the most convincing.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
TV shows and movies are coming soon. Subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don’t miss a single one.